العلاقات مع مصر تدار
بشكل جيد وبين الحكومات كل الوقت هناك
بطبيعه الحال واحد كل منا لديه المصالح
لمصر لديها الامور التي تركز عليها وانا
هم يقلقون لمصالحهم ونحن نقلق لمصالحنا
وفيما يتعلق بقطر انا لا اتراجع عن اي
كلمه قلتها انا ان اتنازل عن مسار واحد من
الضغط على حماس ومن يستطيع ان يضغط على
حماس من اجل اعاده مخطوفين
قطر تضم
وتستضيف حماس وايضا يمكنها ان تضغط على
حماس والتزمت ان تؤكد لنا الوصول الادويه
وايضا للمخطوفين وايضا قالت
انه ايضا جاءت وقالت انها يمكن ان تقوم
بذلك وايضا هي ك وسيط يجب ان تؤكد وتضمن
ذلك وايضا
ان نتحدث بهذا
الشكل سيدي رئيس الوزراء
هل هل موضوع حكومه تكنوقراطيه في غزه بدون
السنوار هل هي رد على
مطالبك لا لا نحن سنقضي على قياده حماس
كما التزمنا وفي اليوم بعد حماس لن يكون
هناك هذا النظام يكون لديه القدرات
العسكريه
والمدنيه سيتم تدميرها وايضا كما قلت كما
هو واضح لكم انه يجب ان يكون هناك جهه
اخرى وايضا اداره
تكنوقراطيه وايضا هذه هذه الجهه لا يجب ان
تكون تربي للارهاب